Alright guys, so in this video, I will go over the four hour auto block trading
strategy in detail. I have uploaded a couple of videos on this topic on
YouTube, but in this video I will explain it in detail. Okay, so basically it is an
auto flow trading strategy, but it is a bit unique to the normal traditional
auto flow, you know, trading strategy. Okay, so this is how we look at it. So
number one thing is look at the auto flow on four hour time frame. Now, when you
open the charts, let's say you open your USD, okay, you don't want to go back. What
do you see at the current like price, right? What are you seeing? Are you seeing
price going up, creating higher highs, higher lows, higher highs. If you see
like three higher highs like that, the trend is bullish. Okay, and if you see
like a market structure shift and then a break of structure like that, then that
could be your shift in the market structure or a reversal. Okay, preferably I
would like to see another break of structure like that. So three break of
like one break of structure and two break of structures like that. And that
would be my trend reversal specifically for this strategy. Okay, so now that you
know that let's say that you know that the auto flow is bullish. Okay, so in real
markets, this is not gonna look like this. It's not gonna be that clean. It's gonna
look something like, you know, something like that, and then you're gonna have this
and then you're gonna have something like that. Yeah, so you're gonna be
making, you're gonna see price making higher highs, higher lows, higher highs,
like that. Cool. So now my point here is the second point here is you have to
mark out every single auto block. So remember the auto block video that I
thought like before, like auto block 2.0, right? You want to mark out every single
auto block. But when you are, remember this thing, okay, for this strategy, when
you are looking at the higher timeframe, so we are currently looking at the
higher timeframe, right? So let's say that this down move is consecutive
bearish candles. So 123 bearish candles. Okay, when you're looking at the higher
timeframe, which is the four hour, you want to refine it. Okay, so let's say
there are three candles in this leg here, you want to mark out the body of the
last candle here. Okay, so in the auto block 2.0, remember we use the body of
the candle. So you have three bearish candles, 123, that is a whole auto
block. But we refine it, we are going to refine it. Okay, we refine it and this is
the candle. So not what we are gonna wait for is price to come back into our
auto block. Once that happens, we drop down to 15 minute timeframe. Okay, so you
mark out, oops, mark out OB, near price action. Okay, wait for price to come
back into your OB, look for market structure shift during kill zone ours,
and entry during kill zone ours as well. Okay, so you wait for price to come
back into your auto block. Okay, so once that happens, you drop down to 15
minutes timeframe, you look for market structure shift during kill zone ours.
Now, when you're at 15 minute timeframe, so we are only using like two time
frames for the strategy for our and 15 minutes, we're not going to use any
other timeframe. Okay, for our and 15 minutes. So now that you have a market
structure shift on 15 minute timeframe, now you have to use the consecutive
bearish candles as your auto block. And remember this one thing, a lot of
people don't get this right. So if you have something like this, price did not
take out the low here and then you have, let's say a maybe a break of structure
here, there was some structure here in price broke it. That is a low probability
setup. I want my auto block to take out some sort of liquidity. So these are
the consecutive bearish candles, right? It if it takes out some form of liquidity
could be just be a like a little low here, right? It takes out and then you
have a market structure shift. Now that guys, that is a high probability
auto block. And let's say that there is a breaker block here as well, right? So,
you know, you know, the definition of breaker blocks, right? The first candle
of this here. And the first candle and the first first candle is like the of
this leg, right? So this leg right here, the first one of this leg and the first
candle of the auto block are in alignment with each other. The size is the same
here. Okay. So you mark out this level right here, right? This is consecutive
bearish candles on 15 minute. Okay, you take your entry right there and you
target one to two. You go for one to two for this trading strategy, guys. Okay,
and you're going to you're going to have above 58 to 60% wind rate with this
strategy. Okay, I'm not going to say you're going to have like a 70% or 80%
wind rate. You're going to have 58 to 60% wind rate. You are going to easily
pass your FTM or challenges or prop from challenges. If you follow the
strategy correctly, remember this works with every single pair. I do not try
this with indices. I will recommend you do not try this with indices. You can
back test it, but the thing is try with forex. Okay, every single pair here,
except these, these ones. Okay, just use these main ones. So here's the risk
management for this strategy. Okay, so once you once the price hits one to one
risk to reward, let's say price hits one to one risk to reward, you move your
stop loss to break even. And then you keep the trade open till one to two is
hit. That way it is like the least, you know, anxiety free like I would say
it's the anxiety free hitting strategy guys. It's it's quite rule based and one
more thing. So let's let's do this. Okay, boom, boom, boom. So let's say the trend
is bullish, right? This strategy does not require break of structure for the
autoblock to be valid. Okay, so it does not have to break the high over here.
Right. And then you would consider this as your POI or autoblock. No, if you know
that the trend is bullish, you mark out every single bearish candle below the
price action. So let's say that this is a bearish candle, right? And the bullish
candle closes above it. So this is the bearish candle and this is the bullish
candle, right? Even that is a valid autoblock. So you wait for price to come
back into this autoblock, you drop down to 15 minute timeframe, you look for
market structure shift, it's going to happen something like that. You take your
entry and boom. So let's say there was like, let's do this something like that.
Okay, this is a bearish candle, right? And after that, you have a bullish candle
and the body of the bullish candle closes above the body of the bearish candle,
wicks don't matter. So if the body closes above the bearish candle, right,
bearish candle's body, then that is a valid demand zone or an autoblock price
comes back as long as this, as long as the low, the wick is not violated.
So let's say there's the wick of this autoblock, right? So you keep looking for
market structure shift until this level is broken or this level is violated.
Once that happens, that autoblock becomes invalid. However, let's say that you
have an autoblock here. Okay, maybe you have an autoblock here. So you choose
the body of the candle. Oops, my bad. You choose the body of the candle like
that. Cool. And then you look for market structure shift on the smaller time
frame and you take your entry, one to two, simple as that. I'll give you guys a
couple of examples. And then I'll end the video.